today's Nintendo switch event revealed
that the console will be arriving for
299 bucks in the US on march three as
well as a whole bunch of other details
so let's go through those the switch
will be launching simultaneously in the
US Canada Japan Hong Kong and major
European countries although the European
price is yet to be announced the switch
will use a 6.2 inch 1280 by 720
resolution multi-touch capacitive screen
and include 32 gigabytes of internal
storage you'll also be able to expand
that with a micro SDXC card the console
features two speakers at the bottom and
a 3.5 millimeter headphone jack at the
top so it's already one upping the
iphone 7 the publisher revealed that in
handhelds merge the switch has between
2.5 and 6.5 hours of battery life and
the console will support local 8 player
multiplayer the joy Khan controllers
will feature motion control capability
amiibo and NFC support the ability to
function as a standalone controller a
screenshot button which will allow for
video capture in future and ir motion
camera shoulder buttons share
functionality and an HD rumble feature
which can convey different types of
vibrations Nintendo also introduced the
Nintendo switch online service which
will be available as a free trial after
the console's launch the service which
arrives in the fall of 2017 requires a
paid subscription and will support
online
player a compatible smartphone app will
work with the service which will let you
schedule game sessions and chat with
friends nintendo wii yet to announce
what the online subscription will cost
in happy news the company added that the
switch will not be region-locked so
switch owners will be able to play games
from any country you can pick up the
console with either gray or neon blue
and red controllers although the pro
controller will be sold separately for
all the latest and upcoming news about
nintendo switch be sure you don't switch
away from gate [ __ ] sorry